MICHEL DEGRAFF: My
name is Michel DeGraff,
and I've been teaching
in linguistics at MIT
for the past 21 years already.
And I'm the faculty
instructor for the course
on Creole languages and
Caribbean identities.
So my research is about
trying to understand
how languages evolve over time.
And what happens when new
languages are created.
Say, for example, in the
Caribbean in my native Haiti
where Haitian Creole emerged
in the 17th, 18th century.
So we try to understand
that patterns of development
of the languages we
call creole languages.
And in terms of the
structure, but also I
have an applied side
to my work where
I try to understand how
best to use say, Haitian
Creole and other local
languages in education
and how that's crucial
for development
of countries like Haiti.